sky news understands that the prime
minister is expected
to announce that london and the south
east is going to be put under a new
tier 4 uh with much stricter
rules on moving around possibly changes
to the christmas bubble plans as well
essentially tier four is a stay-at-home
message
it could include uh non-essential shops
closing it could
involve tighter rules for hotels
weddings even christmas eve weddings
perhaps
could be placed in jeopardy and uh it
will be greeted with uh
dismay and indeed fury by some mps and
no doubt many people who made their
plans
spent a lot of money already if it's a
stay-at-home message
it's potentially going to wreck the
travel plans and christmas plans of many
many uh thousands of families
now if the prime minister is planning to
do this by law
mps will say well parliament needs to be
recalled for that
we shall see if the prime minister has
plans to do that but
all the signs are that just four days
after the prime minister said at a news
conference in downing street
it would be inhuman to cancel christmas
many people will claim that is exactly
what he's planning to announce this
afternoon